Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一个正在进行的好消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢丽莎·约翰逊的“迈向持续收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都对你适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
丽莎本人还会送出非常棒的奖品。如果你通过我的链接参加挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士进行一对一小时指导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情告诉你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am absolutely making hay whilst the sun shines. I am recording this in the school summer holidays and my children have just gone to the park with daddy. I've got to go to the dentist shortly and I was like I've got some time I can record this podcast episode that's been floating around in my head for a few days now. So here I am, where are you? I hope you are living your best life right now and if not that you've got plans to unwind and de-stress and make yourself feel a whole lot better. Some things that make us feel better and sometimes things that make us feel worse
如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让这成为你的向导吧。欢迎来到“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我真的是在趁热打铁。我是在学校暑假期间录制这期节目的，我的孩子们刚刚和爸爸去了公园。我一会儿还得去看牙医，当时我想：我有点时间，可以录制这个在我的脑海里盘旋了好几天的播客节目。所以我就在这里，你在哪里？我希望你现在过得最好，如果没有，希望你有计划去放松、减压，让自己感觉好得多。有些事情让我们感觉更好，有时有些事情让我们感觉更糟
are socialising and getting out and about. You will know whether that is a good thing for you, you will know whether that makes you feel a bit uncomfortable and not entirely like you are thriving. We are all different and what the pandemic showed us is that sometimes stepping back from social pressures can be a good thing but other times it makes us feel like we're not really connecting to people when we're not meeting people and getting out and about. For some people Zoom Zoom just doesn't cut it. And like I said, you will know where you're at on that. I am very much looking forward to this coming Friday when I'm going to be meeting up with one of my very loveliest friends who I actually trained with. And then life and children have somewhat got in our way. And the pandemic of course of face-to-face antics but we're going
那就是社交和外出走走。你会知道这对你来说是否是一件好事，你会知道这是否会让你感到有点不舒服，并不完全像你在蓬勃发展。我们都是不同的，大流行向我们表明，有时从社交压力中退一步可能是一件好事，但有时当我们不与人见面、不外出时，我们会觉得自己与人没有真正的联系。对某些人来说，Zoom 根本不管用。就像我说的，你会知道自己处于什么状态。我非常期待本周五，我将与我最亲爱的朋友之一见面，我们其实是一起受训的。后来生活和孩子在某种程度上阻碍了我们，当然还有大流行的面对面活动限制，但我们本周末要
out for dinner this coming weekend and I cannot wait and I'm like I'm totally going to pick you up to maximize all of our gossip potential so yeah don't underestimate the value of having things to look forward to and having things to be excited about. My sister-in-law uses her fridge as a method of helping her feel really excited about life. She likes to have like a little list of things she's got booked up and once that list starts looking a little bit light what she does is she makes sure she's booking things so that she can be really mindfully excited about them in advance every time she opens or closes the fridge. So, yeah, that might be a little technique that you find useful. It's a bit like having a dream board, isn't it?
出去吃晚餐，我简直等不及了，我想：我一定要去接你，以最大化我们所有的八卦潜力！所以，是的，不要低估有期待的事物和有让人兴奋的事物的价值。我嫂子用她的冰箱来帮助自己对生活感到真正的兴奋。她喜欢列一个小清单，上面写着她预订好的事情，一旦这个清单看起来有点空，她就会确保预订一些事情，这样每次她打开或关闭冰箱时，都能提前对它们进行真正的、用心的兴奋。所以，是的，这可能是你觉得有用的小技巧。这有点像拥有一个梦想板，不是吗？
But it's on your fridge and it's stuff that's actually going to happen. You could put things that you dream about as well. You could well put your goals for psychology on there as well so that you see it day in day out and becomes part of your daily fabric but anyway this is my roundabout waffle for helping us get on track with thinking about being social being a psychologist? How does that work for you? Do you tell people what you do for work? Do you tell people if you're working in mental health or if you're working in education or if you're working in forensic services, how does it make you feel when you do share stuff? Does it make you feel exposed or does it make you feel good? Do you like being the garden party psychologist? Do you like having people ask your opinion and helping them feel differently or better about things? Or are you finding that when you mention what your job is, that you are
但它在你的冰箱上，而且是真正会发生的事情。你也可以把你的梦想放在上面。你也可以把你的心理学目标放在上面，这样你日复一日地看到它，它就成了你日常生活的一部分。不管怎样，这是我拐弯抹角的话痨，用来帮助我们步入正轨，思考社交意味着什么，作为一个心理学家呢？这对你有什么影响？你告诉别人你的工作是什么吗？如果你在心理健康领域工作，或者在教育领域工作，或者在法医服务领域工作，你告诉别人吗？当你分享这些事情时，你有何感受？这会让你感到暴露还是让你感觉很好？你喜欢做花园派对里的心理学家吗？你喜欢别人征求你的意见并帮助他们对事物有不同的看法或感觉更好吗？还是你发现，当你提到你的工作是什么时，你
welcoming in, you know, complicated questions that you'd rather not have? Or maybe you are finding that your viewpoint is very different to the viewpoint of people that you're socializing with. Maybe in your culture or around your friendships, there's not much of an understanding around mental health. Maybe there's a pull up your socks kind of mentality and get on with it. Or maybe there's just a lot of stigma, shame, kind of guilt inducing stuff around people who do need your service. Or maybe people are even shaming you, thinking you ought to be the service user and not the person offering the services. Maybe other people find it hard to take you seriously as an actual grown up offering useful stuff. Maybe you find it difficult to take yourself seriously in that regard as well. You know, I'm acutely aware of when I was an assistant
迎来了你宁愿没有的复杂问题？或者也许你发现你的观点与你社交的人的观点非常不同。也许在你的文化中或你的朋友圈周围，对心理健康的理解并不多。也许有一种“振作起来”的心态，然后继续生活。或者也许对那些真正需要你服务的人有很多污名、羞耻和内疚感。或者也许人们甚至在羞辱你，认为你应该成为服务使用者，而不是提供服务的人。也许其他人很难把你当作一个提供有用东西的成熟大人来对待。也许你发现在这方面也很难把自己当回事。你知道，我很清楚当我是一名助理
psychologist and I didn't feel like my, on paper, my life was looking as professional as I wanted it to personally given the level of responsibility that I had in my job you know so the things that myself and my friends got up to at the weekends you know Laura I'm thinking about that trip to the Bradlaugh fun times but definitely stuff that's of then as an era, not now, you know, so I absolutely treat all of those escapades as being really important and really fun and part of what has led me to be this qualified psychologist before you. But there was that sense of a bit of a life mismatch, really really that I was doing really proper and important stuff and that was the case during training as well so when I first moved for training I was just renting a room from one of my brother's friends and it just didn't feel like I was
心理学家的时候，我觉得从纸面上看，考虑到我在工作中承担的责任水平，我的生活并没有达到我想要的那么专业，你知道的，所以我和朋友们在周末做的事情，你知道的，劳拉，我想到了去布拉德洛的旅行，美好的时光，但绝对是那个时代的事，而不是现在，你知道的，所以我绝对把所有这些经历看作是非常重要、非常有趣的事情，也是引领我成为你面前这位合格心理学家的部分原因。但确实有一种生活不匹配的感觉，真的，我正在做非常正确和重要的事情，培训期间也是如此，所以当我第一次搬去培训时，我只是租了我哥哥的一个朋友的一个房间，感觉我并不是
a proper enough grown-up actually when I moved out the next year and got my own place it felt much more holistic as a grown-up experience if that even makes sense I felt like I needed to have all of my ducks in a row and one of my clients never heard that expression before and so I had to explain what ducks in a row are so in case you don't know and it might not be a super common phrase where you come from whichever part of the country you live in or maybe even which part of the world you originate from ducks in a row means kind of all of your stuff lined up you know and doing reasonably well so it might be occupational it might be educational it might be relationship it might be your living So it might be occupational, it might be educational, it might be relationship, it might be your living environment, it might be your birth family. All of those ducks are
一个足够成熟的大人。实际上，第二年我搬出去有了自己的住所后，作为成年人的体验要全面得多，如果这甚至说得通的话。我觉得我需要把所有事情都安排得井井有条。我的一个客户以前从未听过这个表达，所以我不得不解释什么是井井有条（ducks in a row）。所以以防你不知道，在你来自的任何地方、你居住的哪个国家，甚至你起源于世界的哪个部分，这可能不是一个超级常见的短语，“ducks in a row”的意思是你的所有事情都排列整齐，你知道的，并且进展得相当好。所以它可能是职业上的，它可能是教育上的，它可能是人际关系上的，它可能是你的生活环境，它可能是你的原生家庭。所有这些鸭子都在
behaving themselves and not like meandering off in random directions. So that's what I mean by ducks in a row. And that may or may not resonate with you too. But this is a little bit of an aside. This was not a podcast episode about ducks in a row. Maybe that is a conversation for another day. This was about how you feel when you talk to people about what you do, whether you choose to, whether you don't choose to. Okay, so this episode is inspired by the recent news about SSRI medication and depression. And what a number of my audience have found is that people who have been taking the medication are then reaching out to their friends, i.e. maybe you as the most senior kind of mental health professional that they know. And it's about the impact of that on yourself
听话，而不是像在随机方向上闲逛。这就是我所说的“ducks in a row”。这可能会也可能不会引起你的共鸣。但这只是一个小题外话。这不是一期关于“ducks in a row”的播客节目。也许那是另一天要谈的对话。这是关于当你与人们谈论你的工作时你的感受，无论你选择这样做，还是不选择这样做。好的，所以这期节目的灵感来自于最近关于 SSRI 药物和抑郁症的新闻。我的许多听众发现，那些一直在服药的人随后会联系他们的朋友，即你可能是他们认识的最高级别的心理健康专业人士。这是关于它对你自身的影响
and the weight of responsibility that you carry as well in the role. And of course, this is also linked to the previous episode that I did with Dr. Tara, where we were discussing what it even means to call yourself a psychologist and who should or could be using this title and whether it necessarily infers a professional trained qualification. So, you know, what we know is that that people especially people that trust you in your friendship role or in your family might well seek your opinion on on this kind of issue really you know people are wondering whether they should continue to take their medication given what's been in the news and it's really difficult you know it would be good if they'd given us a bit of a heads up that this was coming out, because this obviously sends patients, friends, family into turmoil and also can bring up all sorts of complicated feelings around. Is it just me then? So if it's not a chemical imbalance in my brain, am I broken? Am I the problem? Should I be feeling responsible?
以及你在该角色中承担的责任分量。当然，这也与我之前和塔拉博士一起做的上一期节目有关，我们在那期节目中讨论了称自己为心理学家到底意味着什么，谁应该或可以使用这个称号，以及它是否必然意味着受过专业培训的资格。所以，你知道的，我们知道，人们——尤其是那些在你的朋友角色或你的家庭中信任你的人——很可能会在这个类问题上寻求你的意见，你知道的，人们想知道鉴于新闻中的内容，他们是否应该继续服药，这真的很困难，你知道的，如果他们能提前给我们打个招呼说这个要发布就好了，因为这显然会让患者、朋友、家人陷入混乱，并且还会引发围绕着各种复杂的情感。难道只是我自己的问题吗？所以如果这不是我大脑中的化学失衡，我是坏掉了吗？我是问题所在吗？我应该感到负责吗？
You know, guilt, shame. And I think if you're being asked these types of conversations, it's always really useful to direct people back to their GP or whoever is prescribing that medication. So it might be that it's being prescribed by an adult mental health team or for that matter a children's and adolescents mental health team in which case these questions are especially important to be directed back towards those health care providers it may be helpful to to kind of suggest that actually because we didn't see this coming as research being published, that you don't necessarily know any more than is in the press. And your take on medication and your take on diagnosis and, you know, presenting problems is going to be based on a number of bespoke facts, you know,
你知道的，内疚、羞耻。我认为如果你被问到这些类型的问题，把人们引导回他们的全科医生或任何开这种药的人那里总是非常有用的。所以这可能是它是由成人心理健康团队开出的，或者是为儿童和青少年心理健康团队开出的，在这种情况下，这些问题特别重要，应该被引导回那些医疗保健提供者那里。建议实际上因为我们没有预见到这是作为研究发表的，你可能并不比媒体上报道的知道得更多，这可能会有所帮助。你对药物的看法、你对诊断的看法以及你（你知道的）呈现的问题，将基于许多定制的事实，你知道的，
formulations around the patient and around the person. And because you don't have privy to all of that history, it's not really appropriate for you to be the person to advise them. So you can talk through options, but you may not choose to. You might not want that in your life. You know, you might just want to be your friend's friend. You might not want that in your life. You know, you might just want to be your friend's friend. You might not want to be your friend's sounding board for mental health. And that has to be okay. Otherwise, what might happen is that you're holding a caseload of everybody in your work environment, but you're also holding a separate caseload of your friends and family and random people that you meet along
围绕患者和个人的形成。因为你没有参与所有这些历史，所以你实在不适合成为建议他们的人。所以你可以讨论各种选择，但你可能选择不这样做。你可能不希望这样进入你的生活。你知道，你可能只想做你朋友的朋友。你可能不希望这样进入你的生活。你知道，你可能不想成为你朋友关于心理健康的倾诉对象。这必须是可以接受的。否则，可能会发生的情况是，你承载了你工作环境中所有人的病例，但你也承载了你的朋友、家人和在路上随机遇到的人的独立病例。
the way. And of course, you wouldn't be supervised for those impactful relationships, and nor would you be insured, you know, if they took advice based on what you've discussed. So I think it's absolutely important to recognise that you can say no, you aren't being cruel if you you know do refuse to comment or suggest that you're not the most appropriate person to comment that's absolutely okay and it is good to be able to talk through things with someone that's impartial you will not be impartial for a member of your friends or family group even for for a colleague, because you will have, you know, history with those people, and you'll be invested in whatever the outcome is. Whereas, you know, a therapist or a GP is that much more removed and able to be just, just there for the
当然，对于这些有影响力的关系，你不会得到督导，如果你根据你们讨论过的内容采取了建议，你也不会得到保险。所以我认为认识到你可以说“不”绝对是很重要的。如果你（你知道的）拒绝发表评论或暗示你不是最合适发表评论的人，你并不是在残忍，这绝对是可以接受的。能够与一个中立的人讨论事情是很好的，对于你的朋友或家庭成员甚至对于同事，你都不会是中立的，因为你（你知道的）与这些人有历史，并且你会投入到任何结果中。然而，治疗师或全科医生要抽离得多，能够仅仅在那里为
person to hear them with any luck so absolutely not suggesting that you couldn't do it but it's whether whether you should be doing it and whether it's kind to you and to the client to do that um you know you could recognize with them that you can see that this is causing them some distress and that it's okay to reach out for support and advice in times like this and that it doesn't say anything bad about them if they do and that you would encourage them to do that. It's really important to be able to have these open honest communications. So it can be difficult before you're qualified because it you know you might feel that you have a professional opinion but it's whether it's appropriate to share that with people and you know I have absolutely been at parties when I've had a
这个人倾听，如果运气好的话。所以绝对不是暗示你做不到，而是你是否应该这样做，以及这样做对你和客户是否善良。嗯，你（你知道的）可以与他们认识到，你可以看到这给他们带来了一些痛苦，在这样的时期寻求支持和建议是可以的，如果他们这样做了，这并不能说明他们有什么不好的地方，并且你会鼓励他们这样做。能够进行这些公开、诚实的沟通真的很重要。所以在你获得资格之前可能会很困难，因为（你知道的）你可能会觉得你有专业意见，但问题是与人们分享这些是否合适。你知道，我绝对在派对上经历过，当我喝了
couple of glasses of wine and people ask me a question and then before you know it it's like being on the therapy couch with Dr Trent and it's not that appropriate is it really but that said people have said to me you know wow I really valued that chat we had it's really different than what I've got from anyone anywhere else and it's not always about therapy you know people sometimes just value my stance on the world and my stance on things. So yeah, it's just thinking about what is appropriate, what is professional, what is within your, you know, current qualification realms as well. We don't want to be totally renegade, punting out advice left, right and centre, possibly for people who haven't even asked for it you know so when I'm working with clients and we're looking at the window of tolerance they notice when they
几杯葡萄酒时，人们问我一个问题，然后不知不觉中，这就像是在特伦特博士的治疗沙发上，这其实并不是那么合适，对吧？但话虽如此，人们曾对我说：“哇，我真的很珍视我们那次聊天，这和我在其他任何地方从任何人那里得到的真的非常不同。”而且这并不总是关于治疗，你知道的，人们有时只是珍视我对世界的立场和我对事物的立场。所以，是的，这只是思考什么是合适的，什么是专业的，什么是你在（你知道的）当前资格范围之内的。我们不想成为彻底的叛逆者，左顾右盼地到处乱发建议，可能是给那些甚至没有要求过的人，你知道的，所以当我和客户一起工作时，当我们查看容忍窗口时，他们会注意到当他们
start to get better because they start to notice how unregulated the world is and they find themselves wanting to soothe and regulate the world but it wouldn't be appropriate to walk up to a stranger and go I'm really noticing that you're outside of your window of tolerance I think you're using this that and the other strategy because they haven't asked you for that help. So sometimes the power is of being qualified and or experienced in mental health is that we can observe what might need to be done in future. But it doesn't necessarily need to be us who says that or does it. OK, let's take a short break here and i will be back along on the other side if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide filled with lessons and Lessons and experience that will help you get qualified.
开始好转时，因为他们开始注意到这个世界是多么不受调节，他们发现自己想要抚慰和调节这个世界，但走到一个陌生人面前说：“我真的注意到你超出了你的容忍窗口，我认为你正在使用这个那个策略”是不合适的，因为他们没有向你寻求这种帮助。因此，有时具备心理健康资格和/或经验的力量在于，我们可以观察未来可能需要做什么。但这不一定非得是由我们说出来或做出来。好吧，我们在这里休息一下，如果你们在寻找成为心理学家的道路，我稍后会回来，让这成为你的指南，充满能够帮助你获得资格的经验和教训。
So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective book is really insightful for anyone hoping to get onto the clinical doctorate. I really love the individual accounts in this book and found them incredibly inspiring. I've been very worried about my chances of getting onto the clinical psychology doctorate as my path is far from traditional, so it was really reassuring hearing so many non-traditional routes others have taken. Thank you for sharing these together and helping the next generation of students. Thank you. so yeah people aren't necessarily going to know the difference between your job titles you know psychological well-being practitioner assistant psychologist higher assistant psychologist
所以快来看看吧。它就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。《临床心理学家合集》这本书对于任何希望进入临床博士学位的人来说都真的很有见地。我真的很喜欢这本书中的个人记述，并觉得它们非常鼓舞人心。我一直非常担心自己进入临床心理学博士学位的机会，因为我的道路远非传统，所以听到其他人采取的这么多非传统路线真的非常令人放心。谢谢你们把这些分享在一起，并帮助下一代学生。谢谢。所以，是的，人们不一定能分清你的职称，你知道的，心理健康助理从业者、助理心理学家、高级助理心理学家
you know mental health support worker, trainee clinical psychologist or trainee health or counselling psychologist, they're just going to hear, you know, the word psychological or mental health or psychologist and they know you've been to uni, you know, so you must know your stuff but they don't know that you're not perhaps the most appropriate or the most experienced person that they could ask um i would love your thoughts on all of this i'd love to know you know what you do when you're asked for your opinion or whether people do ask or whether you know you tell people that you just work in a supermarket when you meet them as strangers you don't tell them what you do maybe you don't want to bring that to your door let's
你知道的，心理健康支持工作者、临床心理学实习生或健康/咨询心理学实习生，他们只会听到（你知道的）“心理”或“心理健康”或“心理学家”这个词，他们知道你上过大学，（你知道的）所以你一定很懂行，但他们不知道你也许并不是他们可以询问的最合适或最有经验的人。嗯，我很想听听你对这一切的想法，我很想知道（你知道的）当你被征求意见时你会怎么做，或者人们是否真的会问，或者（你知道的）当你遇到陌生人时，你是否告诉别人你只是在超市工作，你不会告诉他们你是做什么的，也许你不想把这些带进你的生活。让我们
have a conversation about this um on instagram you can find me dr marianne trent and um on the facebook group the aspiring psychologist community um come along and join us there and do join in the conversation around this so that we can really make sure we're thickening the narrative here. You might also find that people find you, they connect to you, they sense that you're a great listener and before you know it, you're drowning in life stories that can feel quite heavy or unwelcomed you know I only wanted to come to the party and drink mojitos I didn't want to be therapizing uh and that's okay and you might find that because people see the psychologist in your title maybe on LinkedIn or um you know other areas where you might be networking professionally they might be
来谈谈这个吧，嗯，在 Instagram 上你可以找到我 @dr_marianne_trent，嗯，在 Facebook 群组“有志心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community）里，来加入我们，参与关于这的讨论，这样我们就可以真正确保我们在丰富这里的叙事。你可能还会发现，人们会找到你，他们与你建立联系，他们感觉到你是一个很好的倾听者，不知不觉中，你淹没在沉重或不受欢迎的生活故事中，你知道的，我只是想来派对喝莫吉托，我不想做治疗，嗯，这没关系。你可能会发现，因为人们在你的头衔中看到了“心理学家”，也许在 LinkedIn 上或者（你知道的）你可能在专业上建立人脉的其他领域，他们可能会
saying oh could you just you know create this video for me on talking to people about x y or z um could you talk about this could you do that and it's like well actually i don't really feel that comfortable i don't feel it's that appropriate for me to be offering that and to just empower you to know that it's okay to say no and to direct to other areas other areas of support other people that might be able to support it's okay to say no you're not a meanie for being bounded in saying no and again this might be helpful for you to refresh your memory on what I believe is episode eight yeah I should never doubt myself it's episode eight I just checked episode eight is boundary setting for yourself and your clients and you might find that really useful right speaking of boundaries my
说：“哦，你能就 X、Y 或 Z 与人们交谈，为我制作这个视频吗？你能谈谈这个吗？你能做那个吗？”这就好像，嗯，实际上我真的觉得不太舒服，我觉得由我来提供这些并不是那么合适，只是为了赋予你权力让你知道说“不”是可以的，并引导到其他领域、其他支持领域、其他能够支持的人。说“不”是可以的，设立界限说“不”并不意味着你是个吝啬鬼。同样，这可能对你温习我所认为的第八集的记忆有所帮助。是的，我不该怀疑自己，就是第八集。我刚刚查了，第八集是关于为你自己和你的客户设定界限，你可能会觉得这真的很有用。好啦，说到界限，我的
friends it is time that I get out of my jogging bottoms and into my jeans to go and see the dentist I hope you found this helpful and I would really love your ideas around what you might do in these situations what What do you think? What are your thoughts? Do come and discuss this with me over on the Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent.
朋友们，是时候脱下慢跑裤，换上牛仔裤去看牙医了。我希望你觉得这很有帮助，我真的很想听听你关于你在这些情况下会怎么做的想法。你觉得呢？你有什么看法？快来 Facebook 群组“由玛丽安·特伦特博士带领的有志心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）和我一起讨论吧。
That is where lots of good stuff happens and it's totally free to join. So come and do that, won't you? In the meantime, do come and connect in all the good places i am mostly dr marianne trent but you can also find me as good thinking psychological services thank you for being part of my world sorry this is a briefer episode than usual but you know the dentist calls um take care of you and stay kind bye if you're looking to become a psychologist
那里有很多好东西，而且加入是完全免费的。所以快来加入吧，好吗？与此同时，快来所有好地方与我联系，我主要是 Dr. Marianne Trent，但你也可以将我找作“好思维心理服务”（Good Thinking Psychological Services）。谢谢你成为我世界的一部分。抱歉，这比平时更短一些，但你知道的，牙医在召唤。照顾好你自己，保持善良。再见！如果你正在寻找成为心理学家
then let this be your guide kind. Bye. With Dr. Marianne Jordan My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be OK. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
的道路，就让这成为你的指南。再见。我是亚娜，我是一名心理健康助理实习生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现里面关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容真的非常有趣。有很多不同的途径可以到达那里，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。